>>> A SECOND, BIG LIE FROM THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
HE INCITED THE INSURRECTION AT
THE CAPITOL, BY REPEATING
BASELESS CLAIMS THAT THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
NOW, TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES ARE
TRYING TO CONVINCE US THAT
NOTHING REALLY HAPPENED, ON
JANUARY 6th.
HE IS TRYING TO GASLIGHT ALL OF
US, INTO THINKING THAT WE CAN'T
BELIEVE WHAT WE SAW, WITH OUR
OWN EYES, THAT DAY.
HE CLAIMS THE RIOTERS POSED ZERO
THREAT, AND WERE HUGGING AND
KISSING POLICE.
WELL, THIS VIDEO TELLS THE
TRUTH.
THIS IS D.C. POLICE OFFICER
MICHAEL FANONE.
HE IS BEING DRAGGED AND BEATEN
BY A MOB OF RIOTERS.
THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY HAPPENED,
RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOUR EYES.
THERE IT IS.
HE WAS TASERED, SEVERAL TIMES,
IN THE BACK OF THE NECK.
INJURED, ON THE GROUND.
SURROUNDED BY RIOTERS.
HERE IS OFFICER FANONE,
DESCRIBING WHAT HAPPENED, NEXT.
>> I MEAN, I WAS JUST, YOU KNOW,
TRYING TO FIGHT AS BEST I COULD.
I REMEMBER, LIKE, GUYS WERE
STRIPPING ME OF MY GEAR.
THESE WERE RIOTERS, PULLING MY
BADGE OFF MY CHEST.
THEY RIPPED MY RADIO OFF OF --
OFF MY VEST.
STARTED PULLING, LIKE,
AMMUNITION MAGAZINES FROM THEIR
HOLDER, ON MY BELT.
AND THEN, SOME GUY STARTED
GETTING AHOLD OF MY GUN.
AND THEY WERE SCREAMING OUT, YOU
KNOW, KILL HIM WITH HIS OWN GUN.
I JUST REMEMBER YELLING OUT THAT
I HAVE KIDS.
AND IT SEEMED TO WORK.
SOME PEOPLE IN THE CROWD STARTED
TO ENCIRCLE ME, AND TRY TO OFFER
ME SOME LEVEL OF PROTECTION.
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE ASKED ME, YOU
KNOW, MY THOUGHTS ON THE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE CROWD THAT,
YOU KNOW, THAT HELPED ME OR --
OR TRIED TO OFFER SOME
ASSISTANCE.
AND I THINK, KIND OF, THE
CONCLUSION I'VE COME TO IS,
LIKE, YOU KNOW, THANK YOU BUT
[ BLEEP ] YOU FOR BEING THERE.
>> WELL, THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
HUGGING AND KISSING, DOES IT?
OFFICER FANONE SUFFERED A HEART
ATTACK AND CONCUSSION, THAT DAY.
NOW, HE IS DEALING WITH A
TRAUMATIC-BRAIN INJURY, AND
POST-TRAUMATIC STRESS.
JOINING ME NOW IS HIS MOTHER,
TERRY FANONE.
THANKS FOR JOINING, APPRECIATE
IT.
>> YOU ARE SO WELCOME.
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
FOR A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON
WHAT HAPPENED THAT DAY.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
WELL, WE'RE GLAD YOU ARE HERE.
AND AS YOU KNOW, I MEAN, IN FULL
TRANSPARENCY, I HAVE BEEN
TALKING TO YOUR SON FOR THE
PAST-FEW MONTHS.
WE HAVE BECOME FRIENDS.
I'VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT HIS
STORY.
HE'S REALLY A TRUE HERO.
HOW ARE YOU AND YOUR FAMILY
HOLDING UP RIGHT NOW?
>> UH-HUH.
YOU KNOW, THAT -- THAT CLIP,
WHICH I HADN'T HEARD IN A WHILE,
THAT DOESN'T EVEN BEGIN TO TELL
THIS STORY.
IT DOESN'T EVEN BEGIN TO TELL
THE STORY OF WHAT OUR FAMILY
WENT THROUGH.
AND WHAT HE WENT THROUGH, THAT
DAY.
>> I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE BUT HE'S
SO LUCKY TO HAVE YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY SUPPORTING HIM.
BUT I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO THE
FORMER PRESIDENT CLAIMING THAT
THE RIOTERS, WHO ATTACKED YOUR
SON, ARE BEING PERSECUTED.
HERE IT IS.
>> THEY GO AFTER PEOPLE THAT, I
GUESS, YOU'D CALL THEM LEAN
TOWARD THE RIGHT AND THEY WAVE
AMERICAN FLAGS.
IN MANY CASES, THEY ARE WAVING
THE AMERICAN FLAG AND THEY LOVE
OUR COUNTRY.
IT WAS A ZERO THREAT, RIGHT FROM
THE START.
IT WAS ZERO THREAT.
LOOK.
THEY WENT IN.
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT.
SOME OF 'EM WENT IN, AND
THEY'RE -- THEY'RE HUGGING AND
KISSING THE POLICE AND THE
GUARDS.
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE -- THEY HAD
GREAT RELATIONSHIPS.
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WERE WAVED
IN, AND THEN THEY WALKED IN AND
THEY WALKED OUT.
>> HE SAID THEY WERE HUGGING AND
KISSING THE OFFICERS.
BUT, LISTEN.
HE -- HE IS SAYING THAT THE
RIOTERS WERE WAVING FLAGS.
BUT THIS BODY-CAMERA FOOTAGE
SHOWS THEM USING THE FLAGPOLES
TO BEAT YOUR SON.
SO, WHAT GOES THROUGH YOUR MIND,
WHEN YOU HEAR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRYING TO REWRITE
HISTORY ON JANUARY 6th?
SAYING, OH, THERE WAS ZERO
THREAT?
>> YOU KNOW, IT WAS -- I
RESPECT -- THAT'S HIS OPINION.
THAT WAS HIS PERSPECTIVE.
HIS PERSPECTIVE WAS FROM -- HE
WASN'T THERE.
WHAT GOES THROUGH MY MIND, WHAT
IS REALLY OUTRAGE THAT NOT ONLY
THE 850 MPD OFFICERS THAT WERE
THERE.
BUT -- BUT OFFICERS FROM
DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS, AS WELL
AS CAPITOL HILL POLICE.
IT'S DIMINISHING.
IT IS DEVALUING.
IT -- THE THING THAT IS SO
PROFOUND IS, AFTER HE MADE THOSE
STATEMENTS, THE SILENCE THAT
FOLLOWED.
AND WHERE WAS THE OUTRAGE FROM
OTHER PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE,
FROM CONGRESSMEN, WHO WERE
THERE?
AND THE SILENCE, TO ME, IMPLIES
INDIFFERENCE.
AND IT -- I COULD BE WRONG BUT
INDIFFERENCE OR COMPLICITY.
JUST COMPLETELY -- OR -- OR
PEOPLE JUST SO -- THEY'RE SO
USED TO HEARING THIS RHETORIC,
THEY DON'T EVEN -- THEY DON'T
EVEN LISTEN, ANYMORE.
SO, FOR US, FOR OUR FAMILY, AND
FOR EACH AND EVERY POLICE
OFFICER THAT I KNOW.
THAT -- THAT MICHAEL'S IN TOUCH
WITH.
CONSTANTLY, IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
IT'S SO DEHUMANIZING.
IT'S SO DEVALUING.
AND IT'S -- IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> WELL, MS. TERRY, IF YOU COULD
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
IF YOU COULD SPEAK DIRECTLY TO
HIM AND HIS SUPPORTERS WHO ARE
PUSHING THESE LIES ABOUT THE
RIOTERS, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
THEM?
>> WHERE IS YOUR COURAGE?
WHERE IS YOUR COURAGE?
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE OUT THERE.
I KNOW WHAT I KNOW WHAT I KNOW
AND I KNOW THE PEOPLE THAT --
THAT -- THAT HAVE IMPLIED, AND
HAVE -- HAVE STATED TO MICHAEL,
DIRECTLY.
THAT THERE -- THERE'S SO MUCH
MORE TO THIS STORY.
BUT SO MANY PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO
COME OUT AND TO SPEAK.
AND TO SPEAK THE TRUTH.
>> UH-HUH.
>> THE SILENCE IS SO PALPABLE.
AND IT'S -- IT'S JUST
OUTRAGEOUS.
FOR -- FOR ME TO SAY ANYTHING TO
TRUMP WOULD BE -- WOULDN'T
MATTER BECAUSE HE -- HE JUST
CAN'T HEAR.
IT'S ALL THE OTHER PEOPLE, THAT
ARE SO COMPLICIT IN THIS.
THAT'S WHO I WOULD SPEAK TO, IS
THAT, HOW DARE YOU?
HOW DARE YOU?
HOW DARE YOU TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE PEOPLE, WHO WERE DEFENDING
AND FIGHTING FOR THEIR LIVES?
THAT DAY.
TO SAVE THESE PEOPLE, PRESERVE,
YOU KNOW, DEMOCRACY, CIVILITY,
TO RESTORE THE CAPITOL TO -- TO
WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE.
WHERE ARE YOU?
THE -- WITH ALL OF THESE
OFFICERS STOOD WITH YOU, WHY
DON'T YOU STAND WITH THEM?
>> THE PROSECUTORS HAVE CHARGED
THOMAS CIVIC IN THE BRUTAL
ASSAULT OF YOUR SON.
HE IS ALSO ACCUSED OF STEALING
MIKE'S BADGE AND RADIO, WHICH HE
FINALLY ADMITTED THAT HE BURIED
IN HIS OWN BACKYARD.
IS -- HOW DOES MIKE FEEL ABOUT
IT?
BECAUSE I KNOW HE SPOKE TO ME.
HE FEELS -- HE FEELS ENCOURAGED,
IN KNOWING THAT HE BELIEVES THAT
THIS -- AT THIS POINT, THAT
THESE RIOTERS GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
AM I CORRECT?
>> UH-HUH.
YES.
YOU KNOW, AND IT IS -- HE DOES
FEEL LIKE THERE -- THERE'S GOING
TO BE SOME ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND -- BUT, YOU KNOW, THERE --
THERE ARE DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
PEOPLE WHO SLIP THROUGH THE
CRACKS, AND ARE NOT GOING TO BE
FOUND, IN ANY WAY, SHAPE, OR
FORM.
SO IT'S JUST A MATTER OF FACT.
BUT, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHATEVER FINE THESE PEOPLE OR
WHATEVER JAIL SENTENCE SOMEBODY
MIGHT INCUR, IT DOESN'T EVEN
BEGIN -- IT DOESN'T BEGIN TO
REPAIR THE DAMAGE THAT HAS BEEN
DONE TO, NOT ONLY MICHAEL BUT,
ALL THESE OTHER PEOPLE.
WHO -- WHO -- WHO REALLY WERE --
THEY WERE THE ONES THAT WE